lately there's been all this talk about
high value men but it's left me
wondering what is a high value woman
today we're on the streets of Miami to
find out exactly what is a high value
woman since these girls have been wild
and what is a high value woman I think
they're independent what do you think
men look for in women like what are the
most important factors I think it
depends Independence do you think men
look for Independence just depends on
the area like I think when it comes to
Miami men are here are going to look for
the looks mainly and they're like social
status and I think if you go somewhere
else like probably [__] Texas they care
about like a hard-working Ranch girl but
yada yada does body count matter in a
woman um most definitely what do you
think
um
no what's a high value woman someone
would respect for herself the woman has
to give the guy the highest level of
respect does body count matter in this
day and age no why do you think the
women are all trash nowadays because
they don't have no respect for
themselves they go back to my
Owen said the influence that's out there
you know it's it's no good yeah yeah
cardi B promoting degeneracy everyone
following Kim Kardashian that that kind
of [__] right and their kids are all
screwed up you know they're like
freaking only fans and [__] yeah they're
all getting high on freaking the
craziest drugs they don't even know
which way a boy or girl freaking this
and that I want to be a cat it's
ridiculous but not only that it's been
messed up for a while what are the most
important things a guy looks for in a
woman probably loyalty is number one I
just roll with with my girl with five
foot roll if she gets close to another
guy five feet that's cheating if she
talks to another man it's cheating she
looks at another man it's cheating
loyalty is number one how many bodies is
too many in a girl well anything above
zero is disgusting and uh they're pretty
much poison for Life what do men look
for in a woman they look for a pretty
face at first pretty face of course and
don't put problem for nothing that it is
that
foreign
who's better at self-improvement men or
women woman so do you have any room for
self-improvement yes are you a 10 yes
can always improve yourself even though
do you know what a 10 means it means
like out of 100 people you're like
number one I consider myself a 10 For Me
Maybe for you I'm a one what what makes
a woman high value ambition let's be
real here like when you're looking at a
girl like what are the what are the most
important things you're looking at in a
partner like in a partner or like a
partner okay so personality is one we
all know like for sex it's just looks
like yeah but like but for a girlfriend
what I mean like body counts too
obviously we're in Miami like what's the
ideal body count I mean like in Miami I
guess like under 10 is
what's the number like the idea oh under
two the number like what would you pick
if you could pick any number out there
one body zero body oh zero okay but like
that's not that's not the that's not
possible I know so like what's what's
like three or four is probably like past
that you get a little like yeah but in
Miami but I don't think that's possible
either basically like three or four like
that you can't get mad like you that's
respectable boyfriends yeah yeah yeah
what about you yeah let me interview you
what's your ideal woman what's my idea
like a girl with a fat ass
that's one part of it but you know
obviously personality no I don't have a
girlfriend you want to help me get one
my new girlfriend today you like older
women younger women what you like oh I
like older women Excuse Me Miss would
you like to get in my video today no I
guess no we got dub you gotta use the
dog bro the dog's the chico is that why
you're out here no do you guys want to
answer a quick question come here I got
you no no no no where do you guys come
on
let me run away
it's because you're black
yo you know what we should do when I'm
filming an interview run up and be like
Sunny fast nah then I look like a fan
I'm not a fan I'm not a fan of Sunny
fast yeah at least what do you do for
the homies bro that's what me and my
homies do I got you even my one how many
followers on a tick tock you got on
YouTube like half a mil half a mill
why'd you get a white dog isn't that
like kind of [__] up are you racist
bro what the [__] bro I'm trying to are
you racist like come on what's up of
course everyone's racist yeah bro black
people hate white people what's up with
that yeah because you guys let me not
get into this I have to make it out the
Matrix bro like I can't like but it's a
cute puppy let's get him a girlfriend is
that what we're doing yes we're getting
you a girlfriend tonight bro this guy's
gonna get me a girlfriend that's crazy
excuse me excuse me oh no they see
they're racist bro oh look at that bro
bro I thought you liked personality I
thought you like hard work what are you
looking at are you looking at her hard
work right now look at that hard work
she got ambition she gotta drive for
real girls you want to answer a quick
question for a video am so what are they
they're racist too how often do you deal
with like racist people like for real
like is it a common occurrence oh yeah
you can actually do it she gonna come up
you want to bite the puppy again
no no no do you think my friend is
attractive this is my my brother here
he's looking for you know some loving do
you want to answer a quick question for
a video what makes a woman high value we
have inherent value so we just are who
we are what gives you guys inherent
value because we are here you give birth
and we all have value some people have
more value than others than like the
sexual
rude facts don't care about your
feelings she was talking about we are
all humans like what bro women bro
watch out
that's the start of my uh what's today's
date July 14 2023 is the day I blew up
yo stop talking about first of all you
got some Jordans bro what's wrong with
these even your cameraman got a better
fit let's look at a cameraman in the
camera look look we've got a better
figure
bro who the [__] do they think they are
telling you that dog needs water bro
like you to give me instruction over my
[__] dog bro like bro they're yelling
at us the dog needs water bro like what
makes a woman high value if she doesn't
sleep with a lot of guys and she stays
in her feminine energy
whoa you're based so does body count
matter
different for men and women yes how so I
think women need to be careful who they
sleep with because no decent guy is
going to want to marry a girl who's been
with everyone do you care about body
kind of guy I don't want to know so I
don't ask are you vaccinated no oh my
God my name's Sonny
Macy it's very nice to meet you where
you live in Miami yeah I live in
Brickell oh nice are you married
look at that all right well we're going
to a party later after this you want to
tag along
here let me grab your number
wzerca hello
hello what's your name Hannah
dog I think your dog is really cute okay
you know if you lick she thinks you're a
baddie yes has she licked you yes cap do
you think a body
um girl's body count matter yes why I
feel like it tells you a lot about her
standards so like what would you say is
a number that's like oh no she's a treat
any number above four and uh you think a
guy body counts matter no no oh why I
feel like a guy could have sex with
women without any sort of attraction or
connection but I feel like with a woman
it's a bit more uh yeah oxytocin gets
involved and there's definitely a
connection but over so wait are you
speaking from experience no oh I'm just
saying overall nobody should be having
sex before marriage anyways have you
broken that deal no oh bro I love this
type of [__] bro why don't you do it
like why haven't you ever just like
tried it because I I don't have like the
[__] cameraman I don't have this I I
need someone like you know what it is I
think in life starting is always the
hardest thing bro what do I always say
Alex
I literally say that all the time but
like it's just like when do I start this
like I don't think of it right I'm also
in college bro so and like now that I
moved here I think I should really start
this but I you see this is where this is
where I use you you know everyone needs
like a little boost so you come into
play Sunny let's really see if you're
really sunny well actually to the top
dog water oh oh thank you the dog's fine
I've never seen this many people
concerned over a dog drinking water
before
[Music]
die dog is not gonna die he's fine bro
what is am I missing something this
looks like a perfectly healthy dog oh I
came out he drank he ate like please or
animal like whatever because you're
black bro bro don't call bro I don't
know who these [__] think they are bro
why are you yelling at me the [__] did I
do to you but like if I keep getting
attacked I'm gonna go put the dog and
come back bro give your dog some water
bro like what do you guys not have water
where you're from yo but watch that
mouth
on Dreams they're [__] people that
are [__] attacking me bro I don't
align with those white people those are
trash ones that's gonna arrest me and my
dog or because my dog is white the dog's
gonna be free and you're gonna arrest me
what is a high value woman I don't know
because I love thick [__]
what makes a woman high value if she's a
virgin she's a virgin yeah she's having
good morals having good morals does body
count matter it don't matter for the guy
don't matter for the girl do you think
that sleeping around is the same for men
and women yes I think men are more
[__] than women are it depends on the
person who has easier sexual access men
or women women men you think men have
sexual accesses women do because yeah
who is it easier to get if you want sex
who is it easier for a man or a woman
girl approaches a guy yeah it's like
instant yeah so if it's like so
accessible for you would you say that
it's the same value as a guy sipping
around it's like if a girl has 10 bodies
it's still the same as a guy having 10
bodies yes what makes a man high value a
man that can be in a position to make a
woman feel comfortable being in her
feminine so oftentimes men look at women
and say she's not high value but the
problem is is not a lot of men can make
women feel comfortable enough to be in
their feminine for them to become high
value women will operate different ways
around different men so it's up to a man
to be able to inspire the feminine
behavior in a woman can men cry in front
of their woman I've cried in front of
her it brings us close to every time but
when I when I cry it's like it's not
coming from a place of desperation like
my life's so hard help me like this is
you have like what do you like lose a
family member or something well it's
it's more of just like expressing where
I really feel about things like I can
you were having a very deep conversation
about correct yeah and that's what we
love she loves to do yeah I love to do I
think women in general love to do and
that's where a lot of guys fall short
because they don't know how to go deep
with women and have those type of
conversations that women really need to
feel connected does body count matter it
depends on how conscious I think the
woman is like oftentimes women can be I
didn't want to say like is it different
between men and women I think so I think
women inherently want a man that has
more experience that can lead them now
maybe there's a certain point where that
cuts off but I think women would rather
have a guy that is experienced enough to
be able to lead them in the way they
want to be led I don't know what you
think about like a woman would not never
naturally prefer a virgin they'd want
someone with experience virgin but not
like a [__] boy either yeah that's
that's the answer I typically get
oftentimes women are more sexually
active but they don't give a deeper
level of their Emotional Self to those
men and if you're that guy that a woman
feels safe enough to finally open up to
emotionally I think there's something to
be said about that I don't even promote
like hook up culture because like I do
YouTube and stuff and I think it's bad
both sides I at least recognize that men
sleeping around and women sleeping
around is different but I do think it's
like taped to an extent and the more you
do it that tape becomes less sticky and
you're less able to make a real
emotional and spiritual connection with
your partner for men for men and women
yeah no that's what I'm saying yeah
thank you so much for watching
what's a high value woman someone who
has their own goals and values
theirselves he's looking at
personalities all night walking around I
have a very simple answer somebody
that's not gonna cheat on me loyalty hey
respect you know what I'm saying respect
over love you know what I'm saying
because I got a lot of Dreams got a lot
of big goals in life no I like making
music and if a shorty over here just
trying to [__] around random ass people
it's gonna hurt a [__] you know what
I'm saying so you gotta just gotta chill
bro how many bodies is too many more
than me less than me too all right thank
you guys I appreciate you bro you gonna
say goodbye to your cousin my brother
bro it's okay we all look alike bro
all right let's do the outro all right
thank you guys so much for watching make
sure to like subscribe we got some
pretty good answers tonight I still
don't know what a high value woman is
but we'll see you later and follow black
G
H guys let's get this to 500. we've
never hit 500 likes if we could hit 500
pound notification right now
oh my God iPhone
[Music]